they've been stargazing at Arma for 200
years well this is a real piece of
astronomical history this is the
troughton equatorial telescope and it's
the oldest telescope in the world in its
original setting in a dome
The Observatory here and another are
done sink near Dublin placed this island
on the world map their contribution to
scientific discovery well astronomical
this catalog here the NGC catalog the
new general catalog is probably the
piece of work which we're most famous
for this is a catalog of the most
interesting objects in the night sky the
nebulae and it was mapped and cataloged
here using a telescope which still works
today in Amar we basically are
forecasters of solar activity a dunsync
Observatory they're using data from the
European space agency's solar Orbiter
mission to study the sum
and cross-border cooperation has
replaced this ancient technology with
the most modern universities from North
and South having come together to build
a radio telescope at another site Burr
Castle
this telescope is allowing us to study
explosions in the Sun and how they
affect our planet they're helping us to
look at
exoplanets as in small or large planets
orbiting around other stars it's helping
us to look at the very origin of the
universe and where all of the galaxies
and all of the stars and we actually
came from from mapping the Stars to
monitoring climate change science is
fueling optimism in this place at a time
when we do need hope to be able to look
at those jewels in the crown of
scientific research that were
established in the Age of Enlightenment
because of the
recognition of the role of Science in
the development of human knowledge and
the democratization of knowledge I think
it's very valuable to think about
astronomical research inspired The First
north-south Agreement after partition
and it continues to build Bridges this
collaboration demonstrates that there
are some things like science that Trump
the politics of division here astronomy
in particular bringing people together
under the same sky
this small island appears destined to
continue its big impact on Global
Science you could say it's written in
the stars David Blevins Sky News in Arma